lyon c'est ce plaisir aujourd'hui
surtout de projets de petite compilation
de jeux on commence tout de suite avec
musi weather voilà on va jouer le rôle
d'un olala et c'est quoi tous ces gens
là je sens déjà le truc town où on va
être serveur apparemment calibré je n'en
sais rien voilà je joue avec ce bouton
au revoir appuyez sur espace web ohlala
mais attends mais commence à se
contrôler ces coupes mais ont mille fois
pire en laulan salaires 0 euros mais
j'espère bien mon gars ok ok ok
admettons mais cible mais c'est abusé
ben ammar est arrivée va sortir un
moment ce n'est pas possible on veut un
salaire d'au moins un euro s'il vous
plaît les gens tombent bordel henry ok
j'ai trouvé c'est pour vous les enfants
labour mais ya pas de bouffe dans le
plateau pardon je te coupe la tête en
ont mais attend que douch ils sont aussi
abordés juste coupé la tête
si j'ai un patron pas comprendre si on
va faire comment aussi un ok là je vais
y aller mais les gens retournent de
leurs [ __ ] ciel c'est scandaleux on
tient un truc je m'en fous si l'on meurt
jamais khalaf which point ça sur la
table et je toucherai cacher voilà c'est
quoi je gagne des frites nickel mon
salaire est en frites 6000 euros le
salaire monga 6000 euros pour une table
on a joué à ce jour toute la nuit ou qui
ont des bombes à droite droite
j'ai fait tellement peur jusqu'à la
table quoi j'ai j'avais un élan de ce
qu'il est doucement doucement doucement
doucement
tiens voilà merci barrez vous met pas un
vrai faux crâne bordel et vas-y c'est
quoi mon salaire de 1000 euros aulas
holla holla on la tient bouffe moi ok
alors en vendée portant mais bordel et
même des bébés en train d'agoniser par
terre tout doucement s'en fout on sert
un verre d'eau sert un verre d'eau qui
en ont remporté deux mille euros hockey
avance mais avance mais ce mec pouvait
se tenir correctement ça me permettait
de me concentrer un petit peu tiens
parfait tout doucement doucement le
verre d'eau le verre d'eau qui nous
permet de rester en course
si je peux me permettre c'est drôle hein
c'est de s'offrir sa hotte la tiens
boîte au verdon il rigole plus mais oui
monsieur civile sage mais là on va
travailler pour le moi bordel je vais
pas pourquoi l'objectif c'est de faire
tout c'est à mon sens food en fait on a
trois vivent maintenant en là là on suit
largo aspects des frites
je suis déçu moi je préfère être payé en
frisant vrai mais bon
[Musique]
dans un élan de ce qu'il a c'est
incroyable quoi alors les gens décèdent
toujours mais on s'en fout pourquoi tout
le monde est à terre dans ce soir je ne
sais pas il doit avoir une sorte de
virus mais apparemment on s'en bat
totalement les steaks
on leur donne à manger c'est tout en
[ __ ] soit c'est tout petit truc qui
s'envolent bientôt je suis terriblement
déçu rien au monde pourra me consoler à
part peut-être ça oui moi je veux servir
les gens tout au fond jamais servi on a
les capacités vont les choses on les
exploite pas assez il avait là vous
devez leur servait il voyait déjà je
sais vous adorez coq chante m'ont dit on
arrive à la table qu'on n'a jamais servi
il est au poirier de [ __ ] mais c'est
ça les quais près de l'assiette s'te
plaît revenez j'aime et il avait des
lingots sont donc plus je serre les gens
plus gens décèdent j'ai commencé à
croire que la nourriture de ce
restaurant n'est pas du tout bon
regardez le lui fait la planche que son
siège soit à temps mais non mais là j'ai
jamais perdu de manière aussi nul quoi
ceux-ci le dernier essai je vais servir
toutes les tables aux îles à faire du
n'est pas plat oh non mesdames et
messieurs ouvre est maintenant grand vos
yeux nous sommes dans un musée en musée
qui contient des sculptures de ton genre
alors ce jeu à l'air extrêmement bizarre
mais il m'intriguait beaucoup voilà
s'adonnant qu'il a ra et et je sais que
vous avez tous envie à vous avoir dit le
sait bien on peut courir ben voilà ok
chacun des projets ici présents a été
complété en cours en automne 2015 à
l'école l'institut de l'art de chicago
très bien ça va être très beau alors
merci julien menzel merci à mme xu
culture garden waouh
on tient pas trop collant visites
scolaires la holub ont par exemple tous
ensemble allez les enfants suivent et
moi ça va quand on ne voit pas trop loin
si c'est juste un mec et dans les
sculptures auxquels s'ajoutent 10 voilà
en production à son be alors on danse
alors on danse aa façon à l'aider si
tout de suite [ __ ] j'ai peur carrément
et à certains savants survival part à
ces connards de joueurs qui me tue
excusez moi c'est les séquelles de la
rhk survival à evolva d'alors sprit
rightsflow jeunes messieurs dames ce
sont donc des animations créées par des
étudiants chaque étudiant a créé une
image sachant qu'il est uniquement vu
l'image que l'étudiant avant lui a fait
vous avez compris très bien on peut donc
voir ici quelque chose de passionnant
ici un smiley qui plus est c'est super
j'adore aller suivant all alone vous à
ses parents ce texte m'a tout de suite
passé à sale suivante voilà en suisse et
sur le guidon enfermé dans un placard
parce que juste surpris sur l'identité
non c'est bon ce sont donc ici des
peintures du 21e s'est créé par des
étudiants n'ont pas sa salle suivante
avatar partie et c'est ça qu'on veut y a
pas moyen de le lancer de la musique les
bars danser aussi regarder 120 pour
l'activer je suis sûr
[Musique]
où là aussi il ya près de huit agents
qui fera attention ça je me dire au
revoir
merde je suis dans les abysses et au ya
quelqu'un web à cette fois je vous fais
pas danser vous l'avez pas mérité un
hockey aux deux très bien on part dans
l'espace merkel
mes hommes un bébé géant qui danse nue
quoi est ce que je suis pas en avoir
peur un peu gérard là je suis sur mes
gars n'ont ce musée un je me sens
vraiment pas sécurité j'aurais bien
besoin de quelques vigiles avec moi ce
jeu est beaucoup trop d'étranges tournoi
bientôt la plateforme sans nom mais là
je crois qu'il nous faut des adieux
voilà avec c'est fini on en veut
d'autres salles nous a annoncé la sortie
en fait on à aqualand d'accord ça fait
parti de la colombe tous à baal ont dû
aller 30 60 aux côtés de choc
on est maintenant sur in fine et gueu
rageux qui a l'air totalement étrange on
joue une sorte de serre et le but c'est
de créer un accident au cette barrière
est ouvert et si j'allais au milieu de
la route pour faire un terrible accident
olalala violent 11 en fait c'est un peu
comme burnout voilà ce qu'on insère on
enlève rien on est chez nous mais des
images subliminales dans la tête ça
c'est une tentative de manipulation mais
café jeux et un nul minati voilà il me
l'a dit confiante
[Applaudissements]
oh non mais non mais si tu es bête
aaa est valide a voulu vous défoncer lui
du lundi la doulou me des noms mais donc
pourquoi tu bref sur moi des bêtes tout
va bien ah non oh là là oh là là on
dirait qu'on a des critères de mensonges
là c'est pour contrer les lignes que ça
fait du coeur de mensonges là bah voilà
ah non on est à 23000 point je me tiens
voilà à bientôt
merde taureau voilà on ne m'attend sur
matt wells est un jeu qui mélange les
maths et la course seulement voilà sa
porte bien son nom c'est parti neuf +5
égalé 14 donc sur la bonne ligne hop on
est bon 8 +8 égale 16 à sémalens elle
pourrait viser sans déconner temps pour
réviser quand tu es en primaire quoi on
est d'accord 9 + 4 13 un [ __ ] de
hausse s'accélère j'adore ça j'adore
donc si vous êtes en primaire et demain
vous avez un petit contrôle sur les
additions
mettez vous bien c'est gratuit je suis
sûr qu'à la fin ça devait y perdure en
vrai en bref c'est lens manque mais bon
en fait s'il vient de se contenter sur
l'addition et sur le parcours est
envoyée espèce de blocs noirs l'acfo
esquivé annonce est faite à base il a
mis du temps à y aller c'est tout on
veut recommencer c'est chiant on se
retape la la phase de lenteur
extrêmement la jersey dans les bouchons
sur l'autoroute
il ya trois trucs à anticiper l'addition
le parcours et le temps qu'on met h à
changer de voie finalement aller on en a
dans le ciboulot et on le montre
attention à augan savoir un petit peu de
vitesse et un petit peu niveau il est
vrai il est vrai effectivement il
commence à y avoir un certain niveau on
peut le dire et son malin +23 way 7 + 6
ouais en fait ce qui est dur surtout si
le changement de voie quoi c'est pas
l'addition elle même est très simple
c'est plus 4 11 7 + 6 pèse propre suite
11 mois c'est quoi ça extrêmement vite
bordel on s'arrête plus on s'arrête plus
à 14 ans attend mais le changement de
bouaye les hardcore et sportivement on
peut réviser notre contrôle sont cons ou
brusque comme si je trouve où nous
brusquer vraiment moi ça m'énerve sage
et je veux apprendre à mon rythme
d'accord un foyer pas s'ils ont pu mais
plus top 10 ça amène on met mais on ne
peut pas on n'a pas le temps
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas ton ouais
mais ce prix
ah ah ok je me suis pas sommé par un
meuble parfait et ben voilà les gens se
dire prendre cette vidéo j'espère que
vous a plu c'était le cas n'hésitez pas
à aller mais comme d'habitude j'ai
vraiment mal façon on sait que la belle
n'a cessé la vérité voilà je ne peux pas
mentir cette veine les cachets sont
gratuits donc si vous voulez les essayer
par vous-même baleinière sont dans la
description les y foncez réviser vos
matches aux dépens
merci d'avoir regardé le show tout le
monde glisse
[Musique]